[Music]
you know what's strange I don't think I
admit you know or I went backstage to
sort of yeah surprise you I was
undressed but while you were at the time
to surprise that woman and and no and I
realized that we hadn't met before no
one else surprised me it's my first time
yeah I fan of yours for a very long time
though oh that's nice yeah for saying I
used to I used to watch you when I was a
teenager and I used to sort of that's
okay it's alright doing this for a long
time and I'm very very old it's fine he
said crying but I used to kind of have a
little crush on you I love to used to
and it ran away get into that here yeah
yeah I used to watch you all the time
with my friend ELISA back in Vancouver
and we were like obsessed with you
that's so sweet yeah so you and your
friend Alicia I'm just saying late teens
a 16 okay
sixteen through not quite not quite
there yet set of rules up there so your
friend it was quite smitten as well yes
probably still is yes
probably be incredibly jealous that I'm
sitting well tell her I said hello
I will yeah and that in person I'm
incredibly sex I will I will am I let's
just am I your type like you go for like
quirky listen we don't understand you're
married I'm married it's not happening
what what is your type do you like sort
of a quirky jaunty redheaded fellow yes
I do I I mean I think I go for funny
guys my husband is a funny guy and has
been so in starting out live he is yes
yep and I I think I love a sense of
humor I think that's that's one of the
most important things it is yeah it's
wait it's much more important than being
masculine and all that crap I want to
ask you now How I Met Your Mother you
guys finished that show now you are
relocating to New York City and I'm
curious that's a big change have you
lived in New York before I did I I moved
to New York pretty much like the day
after I graduated high school I used to
model and I moved right into this this
bizarre models apartment it's probably
worth millions of dollars now because it
was in the Meatpacking District but back
then it was really dirty and it's where
they slaughtered animals and and models
lived there yeah that seems so strange
to me and it was how many models lived
in one apartment usually about eight at
a time and there was bunk beds and it
was a two-bedroom apartment and and
there was sets of bunk beds and it was
like so filthy this apartment like these
beautiful weird I don't think about
beautiful models playing together being
filthy yes that they were they were so
filthy and they were from all over the
globe and so they would there'd be like
weird vegetables like strewn over the
big sauerkraut out on the table and the
cockroaches would come in and yeah it
was bad it was really bad and it was
really weird I would still want to live
there with those
nothing you say can make me not love an
apartment filled with bottles in bunk
bed I don't care you keep trying oh and
there was love I want to live with the
models and so did you all get along very
well or no I always picture you know
what soap this is a true story years ago
when I lived in LA the first time when I
was working on the The Simpsons there
were these I was lived in a two-story
apartment and the women that lived on
the first floor I found out later on
were models and they used to put on
bathing suits and pose for each other in
the backyard and giggle and of course
I'd be like looking out the window like
a cream pie at the curtain I think they
saw me once or twice you're like he's up
there with all those taxidermy birds
you